hey corridor red here and today I've got
something a little different in mind
that I want you to help me with I have
right here at classic eight and a half
by lemon in sheet of paper about 0.1
millimeters thick really thin if I were
to take this sheet of paper and double
it I got two sheets of paper about the
doubleness again and have four sheets of
paper supposed to double this sheet of
paper a hundred times how thick do you
think that stack of paper would be don't
use calculators don't use Google just do
an honest guess with your head don't
even mean to leave a comment because
we're going to talk about this here in a
little bit today lessons now do you
filmmakers out there a lot of this is
going to seem like basic information but
for everyone else
there's intricacies two lenses and how
they're used and we thought you might
enjoy learning a little bit more about
that the first thing to remember is that
lenses our tools and just like any tool
there's a right one for the job when I
first started working here I had no idea
what those differences were and I'd like
to share some of the things I've learned
with you the first distinguishing factor
of any lens is its focal length the
length of the lens itself is determined
by a process of magnification where the
shorter the length the lower the
magnification and the greater the field
of view now the longer the focal length
the greater the magnification and the
tighter the field for example a 24
millimeter lens is going to give me a
very wide field of view which means I'll
be able to capture almost this entire
room however the 200 millimeter lens is
going to give me a very narrow field of
view which means I can focus on
something particular in the room cygnus
the paper times two to the power of 100
do you think that stack of paper will be
like this thick or do you think they'll
be like a big stack or do you think
it'll might even be like as tall as like
this room that's pretty tall attend
attended can you think always what I was
going to eventually get this column not
polite
I'm gonna guess nice Sunna see Turkey I
probably like a family resistant to the
state of Texas or something or
outrageous it's pretty dang outrageous
[Music]
when I will do the math 500 meters 5
meters yeah okay so the pathetic
perspective that's about half the height
of the Burj Khalifa yeah okay if I get
that's again that is probably the
closest guess inside yeah oh
the next thing to consider is whether
you want a prime lens or a zoom lens
this is a 24 millimeter of prime lens
which means that it only has one focal
length so if I want to get closer to a
subject I need to move the camera this
is a zoom lens 70 to 200 which gives me
variable focal length if I want to get
closer to a subject I don't necessarily
need to move my camera using this lens I
can just punch in and it feels like I'm
closer to the subject without having to
move the camera now there are pros and
cons to each of these lenses with a
prime lens you're going to have
generally less glass inside of it which
is going to give you more light it's
going to allow you to have crispier
image quality the only problem is it's
got a lot less versatility and running
them situation whereas with a variable
lens you're going to get that
versatility but you're going to lose a
little bit of that crispy sensitivity in
low light situations important to keep
in mind that most high-end professional
photographers are going to be using
prime lenses because cost is no issue
and they get really really nice crisp
image quality however it's your indie
filmmakers like us we often go with zoom
lenses simply because of their
versatility its bit of carrying around
the case of five or six lenses we can
carry around one or maybe twos in women
taller taller a Burj Kalifa here's a
hint how far into outer space will it go
oh my god not only with the stack of
paper go across Texas twice
not only would it go to the Sun and back
what this is cradling it how many times
100 what the heck is pushing home from
work if you're to double that sheet of
paper 100 times by the time you get to
100 it is 13.5 billion light years I
said five hundred meters man look at
what it would wrap around the Milky Way
galaxy that's not what it would wrap
around the Milky Way galaxy fifty three
thousand times what that stack of paper
is so sick it measures in billions of
light years I'll glue that you you take
a step wait how how many times you fold
it can't no you can't can't pull it so
how thick is it is 0.1 millimeters thick
so 0.1 millimeters times 100 is what
point no no it's not times 100 its 0.1
millimeters times 2 to the power of 100
the next thing to know about lenses is
that there are photography lenses and
cinematography lens is they're cheap
replaceable and they have auto
functionality such as auto focus and
auto exposure which are compatible with
your average photography camera this 24
to 70 millimeter photography lens we use
a lot around here it's got an auto focus
setting and as you can tell it's meant
to be used by hand with rubber grips for
your focal length and your focus ring
now let's contrast that with a cinema
zoom one this here is our Sigma 50 to
100 millimeter cinema lens as you can
see it's got total manual controls
including this ring on the bottom here
which allows you to manually control
your aperture or however much light your
lens
into the camera sensor now on
photography lenses this is something
that has to be done in camera settings
but on a cinema lens which is this I can
just control it by hand
on the outside of my lens pretty cool
you'll also notice that on each ring on
focus
focal length and on my piece type my
aperture there are these geared rings
this is to allow for hooking up what's
called follow focus this is very very
convenient for the camera operators
because it allows them to simply turn a
dial and adjust each of these
individually not having to do them by
hand like we saw on photography lens as
we saw on a photography lens it was made
out of hard plastic but on the cinema
lenses it's made out of durable metal
this is going to protect this expensive
lens from the ruggedness of a film set
and allow it to last for years lately on
corridor we're building almost
everything using these two sigma cinema
lenses now with just an 18 to 35 and a
50 to 100 you get almost every focal
length that we need which means we only
need two lenses to run a gun they're
super compatible with our red and
they're a great compromise between
quality and price which is something
that's very hard to find in the world of
expensive cinema lenses 0.1 millimeters
x ^ 100 now this is a millimeter divided
^ 104 piece of paper
this piece of paper that's 0.1
millimeters thick all you told me was
that it was a hundred of those stacked
together done and I'm 100 ee 100 mm so
this is one double yes yes okay so and
then I do 100 times but you're not
you're not folding the paper you let's
say you enough so you double you get two
pieces of paper so I really wanna you
have four pieces of paper so that's so
that's one double yes now there's ninety
nine to go yes of this yes only 99 more
of these and all the sudden I'm wrapping
around double it anyway yeah it's not
yet yeah with no your are you for after
ten doubling it is four inches
yeah after 20 doubling your has 320 feet
let's type of paper to go past the moon
willing us to double it 42 42 doubling
its you to the moon bagging it again it
would take 843 trillion years to you
know go along the length of that stack
of paper that is the earth doesn't go
around the universe hasn't even been
around that long
wow that's really really really far
that's yeah and so the reason why is
because our brains cannot even our
brains not physically comprehend what to
^ 108 yet clearly we can but I only have
one more question of that what happens
to carbon fiber paper I'm sorry we have
black holes are made of carbon fiber
whenever you do find it all you have to
do to create a wormhole as you take
carbon fiber and you go like this and it
creates a get a warp in the time-space
be any when you step through to the
other side wait they get carbon fiber
out of work now where it comes from
yeah this'll happen
the Gorske winds came in strong
yesterday
and we have two days to prep for a video
ready if you haven't checked out our
previous videos we test it out some new
microphones we wrapped our YouTube red
show lifeline check it out by clicking
on the screen if you've already seen
them watch them again
[Music]